if I could meet my the person that gave
me the scholarship I would I I would
thank them over and over again it's
really changed my life just by allowing
me to come to this type of school if it
weren't for my scholarship donors um my
I would never have been able to college
I wouldn't be able to see the world like
you go to Qatar go to Spain do all those
adventures that I've been able to have
well I've always felt a connection with
the developing world and one of my main
goals is to use my engineering degree
toward helping people right now I'm at
one of the best clothes for electrical
and computer engineering and I have John
Austin to thank for that rain stepping
laner you know very dedicated the this
was there was a vision you know behind
this gift you know if I can do something
to help realize their vision for making
a real difference in biology and cancer
research they'll be that'd be great I
think the biggest thing about receiving
the scholarship is the fact that it
allows you to kind of you know explore
other options and you're not kind of
bound to worrying about you know your
financial issue and I think you know
receiving the scholarship has definitely
allowed me to pursue the double major to
pursue all these other activities that
I've been involved with we can all be
really focused on our major but on the
other hand we all have these like really
interesting passions and what people do
with that is so amazing Carnegie
Mellon's greatest I guess power is being
able to inspire the world with the minds
that it creates and it sends out into
the world I get inspired every single
day it's just the community of people
and environment that you're in every
single professor all my friends I mean
especially my friends to see what
they're doing at age 20 is just amazing
I doubt I'd be able to do research if
Carnegie Mellon had been here for me
putting someone through a learning
institution like this will teach them
how to think about problems how to how
to learn new technologies how to
approach problems in the professional
world I'm gonna be really good at what I
do because of Carnegie Mellon and then
all the friends that I make here at all
relationships and connections I make
here they're going to last me the rest
of my life so carne mall is basically
giving me everything that I need for the
rest of my life I'm so appreciative that
I'm here and I have all these
opportunities you should be able to not
only further ourselves but further the
place that kind of got us there so
giving back is something that I really
plan on doing and I hope that everyone
does too there would be no devil in mind
that help students through especially at
school at Carnegie Mellon I think this
school is going to grow a lot more in
the next 20-30 years and I think the
students i'll be coming through this
university at that time when i'll be in
position they're just going to be
breathtaking they'll be the ones that
are changing world i would hope that me
and other people like myself who have
chosen to go with a not necessarily safe
major but like really pursuing their
passion if even some of us could make it
and then give back and help other people
do the same I think that would be great
I would love to provide the same
opportunity for another student like me
who would have never imagined to come to
school like this Wow
you